throughout the length of this pandemic
we've checked in regularly with barstool
sports ceo dave portnoy
about how he's holding up during the
lockdowns recently portnoy had his own
scare with the coronavirus he joins us
now to discuss his time in lockdown and
what he has learned
presidency thank you for joining us
tonight so first i have to ask you about
the
extended period you spent in bed sick
did you have the virus
yeah so i did i tested positive so uh
as as we're filming this right now i
just ended my quarantine about two days
ago
so i was inside for two two straight
weeks 14 days
when i made the original video saying i
felt sick i didn't know i had it but
then it got tested and i did indeed have
i think i've had it like eight times
stuff
where'd you get it do you know uh
no well i was in the hamptons and i was
actually with a group
uh it was contagious because like six or
seven of us all tested positive we're
staying together
so i don't know i'd love to know who
gave it to me but no i have no idea how
i got it
you were staying with six or seven
people at once in the hamptons i don't
feel like i should ask a follow-up
question there but i'm glad you're okay
it was a five-bedroom apartment so i
mean it wasn't like we're all crammed
together it was a nice place overlooking
the atlantic it was beautiful
well what have you learned from the holy
spirit i mean you we've been talking
about this virus for months then you
actually got it
what did you learn well i mean i didn't
learn anything differently than what i
thought so
you know i i was very tired exhausted
for two days
within the group of us that were staying
together everybody was affected a little
bit differently
um but you know it it it was a flu it
was a cold is kind of what i expected i
was the oldest of the group i'm in my
young 40s
uh and we had everyone from mid-20s to
my age and for that demo uh some people
got sick
some people felt bad for a day i was
sick for you know
two days and exhausted for really a week
and a half but the bottom line i think
is what i thought it was if you don't
have
underlying symptoms if you're not
already ill or susceptible
and uh you're relatively young you're
going to get sick and you're going to
get over it's highly contagious clearly
but it did it it did exactly what i
thought it would be i i mean it's a real
thing
um if you're elderly or you are health
you know impaired i think it's a real
concern
but for 99 percent of the country it it
acts like the flu
that's kind of what i think of it yeah
well and you experience firsthand so
one of the reasons i admire your
response to the lockdowns is even though
you were shut up in an apartment
you used your time wisely you're already
a mogul now you're a mega mogul thanks
to online trading
what have you learned how much richer
did you get
during the chronovirus lockdown you know
i don't like doc like to talk about
money but my net worth is probably
like almost doubled uh i've you know the
stock market
it just goes up tucker i've turned into
uh i was never a stock market guy i
never traded i always looked at finance
guys like they were pulling a fast one
on me
and i think they work because all you
got to do is buy anything with letters
and it seems to go up like 10
i'm looking at my screen i'm up 600
grand today trading literally today i'm
watching in the background here
it's beautiful i don't know why anyone
has a job all you got to do is buy
stocks and watch them go up
so it's been a very profitable
uh quarantine for me i didn't know that
would be the case but it has been
so but doesn't make you a little nervous
i mean you're sitting in your apartment
you make 600 grand in one day by
investing in companies with letters in
the names
aren't you kind of tempted to just cash
out and like buy a bigger place
you know i'm always tempted but the
nature of my personality i'm
entrepreneur i like pushing things uh
you know
if if i wasn't somebody who always
wanted to build more and accumulate more
i probably wouldn't have started
barstool so
um no yes am i tempted yeah
but i want a mega yacht you don't get
mega yachts with 600 grand days you need
like six million dollar days
[Laughter]
you really have taught i asked you what
you've learned you've taught the rest of
us
how we should have spent the last four
months but most of it and listen
people are afraid and now nowaday i you
know making money i
we're a capitalist society i don't think
you should be ashamed or embarrassed
um and hopefully one day i can give back
to everybody from my mega yacht
yeah well call me if from your stateroom
if you don't mind dave portnoy thank you